hello I'm here Mitch Patel from the film
yesterday and I'm about to take a quiz
here the BuzzFeed which Beatles member
you quiz here we go
pick a Beatles b-side old brown shoe
rain this boy or I am The Walrus it's
gotta be I am The Walrus
what does that mean we still don't know
which country would you want to visit
France India UK or the USA I'm gonna say
India because it's been quite a few
years since I've been and I really want
to go back have a little look around
pick a Beatles movie to watch Yellow
Submarine hard day's night let it be my
help it's got to be a hard day's night I
think for me because it made me laugh so
much there's this moment where Ringo
asks anyone know why there's an old man
in the cupboard that moment just made me
laugh so much
which of these songs should have been a
number one single Eleanor Rigby wasn't a
number one signal do you want to know a
secret strawberry fields forever and I
love her all of them but Eleanor Rigby
that's outrageous pick a Beatles album
that you love to listen to revolver
sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band the White Album Abbey Road gosh
that's like choosing between your
children that's really I'm gonna go with
Abbey Road
I was Abbey Road recently and I can't
get because the world from Abbey Road
out of my head so let's go with that
which psychedelic pattern speaks to you
whoa it feels like you're now just
watching a guy stoned staring at things
like I think it's dawn on the top left
that's like don't even know how to
describe it man finally pick an on
George member of the Traveling Wilburys
Bob Dylan Roy Orbison Jeff Lynn Tom
Petty I think it's gonna be Bob Dylan
because it's Bob Dylan you know I got
Paul McCartney it's pretty good I mean
any of them would be good but he kind of
wrote a lot of the songs right like Paul
you're the eternal optimist who always
looks at the bright side of things and
tries not to let negativity ever bring
you down you also feel most comfortable
in doing something creative which is
very true
and I'm I'm trying to be a bit more
optimistic generally so yeah I'm Paul
McCartney which I guess is what I've
been pretending to be for quite a while
then so here we go
[Music]
you